as my audio still good uh yeah you sound
you sound phenomenal like how can you
ever not sound oh I know
stick waggling let's gather I got to
okay let me read the introduction this
is scary United co-op a Garry's Mod map
rules for best experience
no no clip basic weapons allowed and no
fizz gun using other this is a combined
version of okay blah blah please enjoy
the map let's do it okay did you read
that so beautifully I don't know you're
right mom mom no no none of that none of
that whoa oh hi hello the doors closed I
know you wait I can't open the door
really nothing no I cannot open the
doors so uh you have fun just got it
away I'll be up here no I'm not gonna
fit on it
you better not no don't face gone that
well don't be friends gone in got it I
want it so you go down there I remember
this happening I remember this happening
so you go down they're supposed to be
separated and you have fun whoa Jesus
why ha ha ha oh ah oh you're funny
nobody you're hilarious I know you know
that door cuz I think where do we go
broke it ah maybe we go back here maybe
we don't
maybe we break oh no maybe oh maybe we
go in the really big oval oh oh okay
you're rude oh I hope you know that why
am i rude because you're just like
standing there like leutis idiot I
actually forgot about this so you could
you could take that attitude and you can
shove it up your butt as I honestly
didn't know whatever
been a while it's been a while okay
whatever you say whatever I say indeed
so are we trying to find devil's crosses
we are trying to find
oh hey hi oh how are you yeah we're out
there's a close
oh except we can't die we can carry much
Gary's mom won't let us die uh sighs
okay well anyway open they're not a big
deal that'll be deal Oh mo nice mrow
mrow mrow hey there's a hole in the wall
over the wall wow man I was ported away
um oh wait did he say use crowbars only
yes crowbars only okay oh oh
we wear our sparkles we're Oh what I'm
going through a maze I'm going through
amazing some of my own
oh so scared there's blood all over the
floor sorry I actually don't know where
I am
I like it either I don't remember any of
this I'm stuck I really don't remember
anything that's oh I'm back I'm back
it's okay we're is back cuz I don't see
you okay by crawling through this are
you okay I don't know I don't know
anymore
I hear you smack in the wall just
whatever you do don't alert the monster
behind you don't look at it you know
look at it cuz I we really piss him off
okay oh wait wait I just got tell wait
what yeah what I opened the door alright
oh there there we go we're on Castle
okay alright yeah you're welcome
nothin seep Hey look bull blood you
wanna be honest I'm bathing in it please
oh it
see I was bathing in it and I wasn't
paying attention to it I fear something
exploded something may have happened out
here please just gone why that's crazy
no I'm telling you man it actually
happened why would someone who do
something like that explode oh hi
Topanga Bachchan
where is Harvey Dent worried Rory Dent
who you really are you Batman now Rachel
no I'm Ben I'm Batman
I'm Christian you you do a way better
Batman than I do Batman
where's Harvey Dent where's Harvey Dent
work Rachel I'm going after Rachel
Justice just to finish some fatback
we have a second chance so you can
change it what RV dent is gonna have a
second chance
oh the save Rachel justice has no second
treasures uh just a sort of only one
don't make fun of Batman never never
would do such a tit oh I don't happen I
don't know I suppose but you don't see
me I saw you know you don't so oh yeah
that was supposed to kill you oh yeah
hang on I'll try to free you you free
okay there you go thank you I was
supposed I forgot I ran into that a long
time ago oh yeah I wish we could die why
let us die it's like gmod got updated
and they changed some stuff so I don't
know why I guess so the gmod versions a
newer than the map yeah this maverick
wicked old sow and they recently up to
like gmod three or five or some down
yeah Wow no oh well we were supposed to
die there hey at least a jump-scare
still work that's all it really matters
yeah yeah cuz oh oh oh I was supposed to
die dude I'm so startled carrots I don't
think I was was Cooley Oh No
just a bunch of chairs but I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry
yeah I'm sorry about will you ever
forgive me Roldan if that killed you
that would have been really funny are
you good dick you see what I think we're
supposed to we're supposed to play prop
hunt that's what it's telling us by goal
well let's get some peeps and play some
prep event mm-hmm prep her preparan I'm
pressing E and it's not working I can't
be a barrel
oh oh well whatever who cares oh god
these chairs are really difficult to
walk overs carry on man keep moving
forward okay you just got to keep moving
into those jump scares just keep moving
into the blackness Oh which door should
I choose from I'm gonna choose the
contaminated area contaminated with what
contaminated with his blood hey hey you
hey sir hey get off of it okay
wait sir sir hey so bad I go how are you
doing sir
I'm wakey-wakey come up no no wait sir
sir you're being arrested for being a
douche so I think this guy might be dead
maybe sprinkle some crack on him in
where is it says he can see me and we
can't see him once again and I'm going
to the basement oh that's probably a
good place to go hey hello
I love basements and dark scary places
so do i hey it's a guy over there do we
want to go in here can we open it nope
we can't go you can't oh wait there's
something behind these boxes oh good oh
just a bed just two just your average
ventilate you're gonna coming over there
you know you're gonna come in right
nowyou I'll watch you from you coming
near average everyday ventilation
chapters I don't wait up
no all right fine oh this is oh it takes
us to do the guys going to do it burnt
corpse thing he did oh yeah I did good
for him anyway I remember we need to get
those triangle pieces yeah on the
blackboard in that room it said you
needed the triangle pieces oh did it
yeah so to your left
stop messing around with the corpse oh
do I break them or do I know you don't
break them stop trying to break
everything I like breaking beam is that
about brachytherapy it someone yes we
need to bring it so that we can create
the magic incantation circle to summon
the devil we're gonna turn those another
devil map no maybe I don't know anyway
you bring those oh god I dropped it I
didn't drop it we reject get it
wait no but I saw another one I suck God
door open come on hey come on are you
going back no no no no
the other way okay we are come on it was
there was a triangle thing in the barrel
it was a triangle thing in the barrel
yeah and there's and is this where you
put it see Oh gotcha okay let's go back
to the classroom no you you go I'll go
get a little risk I will risk having
jump scares you you had a jump scare
didn't at a dumpster yeah oh there's a
nice that was a nice reaction sound hmm
oh really they're rushing to me need to
be deeper do hmm man more manly
masculine cuz that's what I am see you
should have gone back to the last memory
booth oh hi okay I forgot it he'll be
got my way possible
I'm singing it out of air I'm taking
them all out are you no no really I
I had a freaking triangle piece I was
trying to get out of here okay cuz I'm
trying to complete the objective and
you're just worried about your kill
death ratio so ah taking out the
headcrabs with with dad okay whoa whoa
oh really oh really are you all right oh
yeah yeah I am
fine whatever what okay whatever
dad I'm stuck a boxer we go there's one
more triangle I think I know where it is
do you now I do
oh hi haha I don't actually know you
when I went back to the class Oh Maria
oh no nice because they're these door
here that have the triangle in there do
oh my goodness Wow
you gotta be okay where where is the
triangle where is it it's by the barrels
no no no okay never mind then no you
were so sure of your saying you know why
I don't need any of your sass I'm Barca
plier I look
throw it horror you shut your face Shia
go mr. Nye Kraft don't you just found it
go just do you guess who just found it I
will I want I will can you open the door
cuz they know the drunk aunt over the
door ha see now who needs who
and I knew yes or are you going to drop
this there we go that's all you are
welcome I don't need you for any war
whatever kaboom hey look man it open no
bends crazy it opens up good for this
long hallway yeah I'm still here all
right okay all right a spooky room fire
ha ha ha ha
that's pirate speak
ok I'm here what's going here let's go
in there you let me go in there yes I
okay there's a baby on the altar is
there oh I've not even stick the baby
and then go gotta go ahead hey I'm gonna
use my gravity gun here yeah you know no
I can't give me give me the thing no
don't do that kind of headcrabs
everywhere everywhere ah let's go this
noise there we go oh nice yeah it's
probably a probably a good good weapon
key hey hey good good master strategist
didn't work okay so so yeah I remember
now
uh wait here I got to go around to the
other side so wait here because you need
to be here when I go push the button on
that right there so I will be back I'm
not expecting anything devious to happen
here I'm totally being serious I'm not
doing anything I'm going to literally
just go and push it a button mmm are you
that you can carry on with your life oh
you're gonna do so you just you just
jump scared that was a jump scare down
here but it wasn't that bad so I'm okay
hurry you didn't have a heart attack you
still with me yes I am fine
good oh hello there was another one I
was really worried for your safety
oh hi hi I wasn't lying okay oh there
you just wait why this is where I die
easy see what I mean you need to get on
the you need doors and push the other
button inside there that should on leave
it open or something okay that oh yeah
my button here okay I'm coming back
don't don't lock me out the well man
says the correct order Oh Locker yeah
man like you outweigh the oh there's the
red button gotta lock me out man
come on oh oh you're in no is your like
car my mouse when I want to yell oh god
another puzzle
oh man oh God don't self-contained or we
like uh-huh we're that oh I didn't see
anything oh oh wait wait this this this
goes back in the thing in the the place
no it doesn't this goes back in the
thing in the place oh okay
okay I got it cover me I'm going in okay
go in
I've got lag it will go through well go
through
I woke out oh oh now the door what the
hell was that
I'm drew Greco where'd it go I lost it
what do you mean where to go I lost it
no you didn't know I'm dead do you see
it is in front of me you've got it you
took your son of a [ __ ] okay okay if I
could kill you I would kill you so hard
right all right damn it
why is gmod after change man uh we we go
to the saw our story that was whoa
acknowledged as if I'm being way too
loud
am i yeah I just wanted to see if
there's anything in there bye am I being
too loud
no you're not good cuz I'm on my headset
cuz my microphone not working it's okay
it's just your microphone was electric
II and staticky but it costs a lot of
money okay any dead bodies in the
freezer that we need to worry about
probably not oh hey it's not the dead
bodies you need to worry about okay all
right seems to be a serious car doors
here Matt guys I move my mic farther
away from my face so I don't have to
worry about it cuz I see by audio
recording it's like
peaking all over the place all right
well that's fine no gate Jesus okay
we're both trying to get inside again
ladies first oh I'm so funny okay that's
way that's why I got various I didn't
find any triangles there oh in the chute
Arvid just a scary ventilation shaft
it's not very so scary okay why don't
you join me why don't you join me in
that merry way oh I'm in I'm in man
that's what that's what he said oh oh ah
ah I made a funny
I baked a jokes here oh boy oh it's a
triangle it's a triangle I see a
triangle yay okay we can get out of here
then all right do you want to open the
door
I got it I'll lead the way oh oh hi I
sprinted right through that I didn't
even see it
No were you not even skirt I was not
scared at all okay whatever man--
whatever mr. meanly me thank you
I know all my fans know how manly and
masculine where'd you get no tell it
where'd you go
I had teleport where'd you go I don't
know yet teleported somewhere I am where
I'm stuck I'm doing oh hi there I
remember this oh hi there oh this would
be so cool if it was working anger what
oh yeah hi this is my favorite of this
whole game I totally forgot about this
one button opens the door one button
kills me and it is super fun hang on I'm
on my way
okay right okay all right so wait no no
open the door don't don't kill me again
ah damn it that's not supposed to be
able to reset okay coming back this time
do not kill me how about we do that you
know what we do that you don't want to
kill you no please don't
okay I opened the door you did okay now
press the correct button I don't know
which one it is but just press it uh
yeah awesome whoa okay so now uh um what
I don't know what that did oh yeah I
took that is that supposed to kill me I
don't know cuz the other one doesn't do
anything and it just opens the door oh
wait yeah all right one more time
scary just Gary chain-link fences yeah
oh so screwed ah ha ha that was killing
you I will kill you
oh this would be so much fun if it
worked dammit come on
Oh kill yourself make it funny how do we
kill myself you type in the console kill
okay good umm oh you may not want to
kill yourself don't do that no don't
kill yourself know yourself tell
yourself okay I keep believing say this
like tell yours oh good kill you're
still okay I'm now I don't even I don't
even know where to go where are you I'm
at the start area Oh see that's why I
didn't know if you were supposed to kill
yourself cuz I didn't know if you were
gonna start there or else oh wait no no
I'm here I'm here okay hi there woosh
alright so oh wow that's fun oh god I'm
falling oh you're de falling yeah golly
oh you fell through this hole in the
ground yeah I fell through this hole in
mayi oh hey you're with me yeah no I
don't see you but I'm here let me read
congratulations you have managed to
finish scary United co-op map did it
take long was it scary was it fun you
keep that information to your head and
maybe the comments section of the
download page please note that if you
did play this alone this was not near
the full experience with friends
everything is funnier also if you're
playing alone right now how in the heck
did you make it here no clip damn you
you want more scary experience check out
my other map called scary map V 101 it
will scare your pants off for real
you'll that's the end you I don't know
how you were reading that because I had
a face in front of me you do yeah oh is
it a good-looking face uh it's a face
with no eyes that's a shame
oh well what can you do give it some
pupils oh I can't see the pupils darn it
I was trying to give it pupils may be
hard oh well well that's the end another
all right well thanks for watching
everyone
yeah yeah yeah thank you we'll see you
next time see ya bye
look why are you killing me
Oh
none of them